un test négatif ou une preuve de
vaccination c'est ce que les fans des
yankees devait fournir pour assister au
match
l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale commence
à faire son chemin ici aussi nous
considérons que le passeport immunitaire
comme un moyen de faciliter le
déconfinement moyen complémentaire aux
mesures de protection qui existe déjà
ce n'est donc pas la panacée mais dans
certains secteurs les avantages d'un
pasteur vaccinale l'emportent sur les
inconvénients
c'est ce que conclut le comité d'éthique
de l'institut national de santé publique
du québec
l'idée de fournir une preuve pour
voyager à l'étranger semble de plus en
plus incontournables mail imposé de
façon domestique pour avoir accès au
secteur des loisirs comme des concerts
pourraient aussi être justifiée d'un
point de vue éthique
le principal enjeu éthique et celui de
l'inéquité l'injustice irait normalement
en décroissant à mesure que l'ensemble
des personnes qui veulent se faire
vacciner de fond le sont tout dépend
donc de quand ils pourraient être
imposées mais le principe divise déjà
oui oui c'était bon c'est une bonne idée
c'est plus un choix du citoyen ça
devient une obligation pour pouvoir
retourner à nos
activités au oui pour voyager pour
récemment d'un restaurant une salle de
spectacle certains secteurs durement
touchés s'accroche déjà à l'idée faut
passer aussi nous à sauver les
entreprises les emplois des familles le
moral des troupes est au plus bas donc
je pense que c'est une des premières je
dirais zeta je pense le milieu des bars
pour d'autres il est trop tôt surtout en
plein troisième vague
le cabinet du ministre de la santé dit
prendre acte de l'avis du comité
d'éthique et se fiera à la
recommandation de la santé publique